the expanse is a sci-fi book series
adapted to TV it's got politics mystery
space battles space Mormons and a
looming alien threat and it's mostly
based in realistic science and
technology the expanse is set hundreds
of years in the future when humans have
colonized the solar system earth is
overpopulated and environmentally
stressed and it's governed by the United
Nations Mars is an independent power
with advanced technology and military
working to terraform the Red Planet
while Earth and Mars are the big
political powers the asteroid belt is a
dangerous new frontier millions of
people live on Ceres arrows and other
rocks mining the belt for resources a
political network called the OPA fights
for the rights of the belt against Earth
and Mars beyond the belt Jupiter's moons
of Ganymede and Europa grow food in
greenhouses there are resorts on
Saturn's moon Titan and labs on the
moons of Uranus and Neptune the farthest
outposts of human civilization Earth
Mars and the belt each have distinct
cultures and histories earth is
controlled by the United Nations because
some time ago earth had a terrible
environmental collapse the ice caps
melted and the sea level rose causing
mass displacement and chaos in the face
of extinction the nations of Earth were
forced to unite under one government
there are still some places resisting
the UN but most of the planets under
control of course within that government
there are factions and conflicts one
major character hew and politician of
acerola fights for peace amidst the
politics so earth is powerful but it's
an empire in decline it's way
overpopulated relying on recycling
machines to keep it from drowning in its
own filth about half the planet is
unemployed living off welfare called
basic basic provides food and shelter
but no money and not much freedom to
make your own choices
so earth feels stagnant bureaucratic and
bloated but it's still the only place
where humans can stand under an open sky
and breathe free air it's the birthplace
of humanity and it's not giving up yet
Mars was settled by some of Earth's best
scientists and engineers they built
cities underground and in domes
developed the best spaceships and
science and soon they decided they
didn't want to serve earth anymore
Mars wanted independence which almost
caused war with earth but then a Martian
called Solomon Epstein invented the
abstain drive a rocket technology that
made spaceships fly far faster and
further than before
Solomon's test drive accelerated so fast
that it killed him and a hundred and
thirty years later you can still see his
ship shooting into deep space the best
longest funeral in history Mars
recovered Epstein's design and shared
the drive with earth in return for
independence
so now Mars has its own government and
military and stands as a rival
superpower to earth but while earth is
bloated and slow Mars is driven and
focused on one goal to terraform Mars to
turn a lifeless Rock into a garden this
shared purpose unites Martians from many
different backgrounds the Mariner Valley
was settled by East Indians Chinese and
Texans so you get Martians like Alex
Kemal who looks Indian but speaks in a
Texan drawl Mars brings together some of
humanity's best and brightest with the
shared goal of transforming the red
planet but Mars as technology and
military makes their rivalry with Earth
dangerous war could bring disaster on
both planets people born in the asteroid
belt are called belters since they grow
up in low gravity belt as a tall and
thin with wake bones some can't even
survive the gravity of Earth they've
become a separate people with their own
culture adapted to space they have their
own language and hand gestures to
communicate through spacesuits in the
show they have special tattoos old
spacesuits used to burn belters necks so
their tattoo to cover the scar now even
unburned belters get the tattoos as
marks of cultural identity these are a
people who ventured into the darkness of
space to explore find fortune and
freedom but the belt is still mostly
controlled by the inner planets Earth
and Mars inner governments and
corporations owned Bell
stations and mines imposing heavy taxes
tariffs and unfair laws some inners a
racist against belters seeing them as no
longer human because of their
differences in response to this
oppression the outer planets alliance or
OPA fights for belter rights but it's a
loose decentralized network that
includes criminal and terrorist elements
OPA leader Fred Johnson tries to unite
and legitimize the OPA
even though Fred was originally a
military leader for Earth at the same
time Fred runs an engineering company
that's building a giant spaceship for
Mormons who want to colonize distant
space so the expanse has all these
different competing factions whose
cultures and conflicts are shaped by the
physics of space like in space there's
almost no gravity which is a problem
because your muscles waste away your
drinks spill everywhere and the VFX goes
over budget a lot of sci-fi shows get
around this by inventing some gravity
plating that magically gives ships
gravity but the expanse is more
realistic because it's spaceships use
acceleration or thrust to make gravity
it's like how accelerating a car pushes
you back in your seat by accelerating
constantly a spaceship can use that push
back as gravity pulling you down towards
the thruster the faster you accelerate
the stronger the gravity so flying at 1g
is earth gravity while two G's is double
earth gravity making you wait Weiss as
much when you're in a hurry or in combat
ships might fly at five or six GS the
expanse has a drug called the juice
which helps people survive this but too
much g-force will kill you an Epstein
ship can accelerate constantly for the
first half of a trip then flip around
and thrust in the other direction to
decelerate for the rest of the trip that
way it slows to a stop at the
destination keeping thrust gravity the
whole trip real-world Rockets aren't
fuel-efficient enough to do this but
with the epstein drive the physics of
thrust gravity makes sense sometimes
though you want gravity without having
to accelerate somewhere so another
method is to rotate an object so the
centrifugal force pushes you outwards
this looks nauseating but
from your perspective inside the object
you're standing still and you've got
gravity it's like the Gravitron that's
been in carnival ride that pushes you
against the walls spin up a whole space
station and that force is your gravity
it's like in 2001 a Space Odyssey but in
the expanse they don't just spin up
stations they take planetoids like
series that are too small to have their
own gravity and they artificially spin
the whole rock to give it centrifugal
force the spin gravity pushes outwards
so people live on the inside of Ceres
underground the the spin gravity in
series and eros is 1/3 as strong as
Earth's gravity which causes the tall
thin bodies of belters like main
character detective Miller so the people
and cultures of the expanse are shaped
by real world physics and by stuff like
communication technology you can't send
a message faster than the speed of light
so we can take seconds or minutes to
send messages to distant planets you
can't talk in real time this creates
tension and strategy in conflicts but it
also has emotional impacts the calm
delay separates people from those they
love making space feel truly remote
technology also changes families main
character James Holden was born in
Montana to a family of three mothers and
five fathers who each contributed to
Holden's DNA sharing one child between
eight gave tax breaks to Holden's family
on overpopulated earth so the expanse
makes some stuff up like the abstain
drive but it also uses real science and
technology to shape its people and
worlds the story of the expanse begins
with Holden who gets into danger on an
ice hauler detective Miller
who searches for a lost girl on Ceres
another sorolla who navigates UN
political intrigue they're all drawn
into a mystery and conspiracy that
threatens everything we're working on a
video about this story but in the
meantime check out the first book
Leviathan wakes you can get it on
audiobook for free today by signing up
for a trial at audible.com slash ASX
members get a free book each month and
if you cancel you keep the books well
has all the main series expands books so
next time you're driving put on
Leviathan wakes and accelerate to feel
the G's of artificial gravity sign up at
audible.com slash ASX or text ASX to 500
500 a thank you to expanse author Daniel
Abraham for help with this script thank
you for watching and thanks to the
patrons including Stephen cook or of Z's
Eagle 23 comm Trent and DJ arruda Cheers
you